just a note if you haven't seen the
april fool's video the ranking of the
toes then click on the link in the
description as i placed quite a
significant amount of effort into it and
people seem to enjoy it which is always
a delightful match
gary nolan is an immunologist an
inventor a business executive and a
professor at the stanford school of
medicine today we talk about subjects
ranging from nootropics to the potential
physical evidence of intelligent life
being behind what are the reports of
ufos including the adverse effects of
interacting with the phenomenon which
was just declassified in late march 2022
click on the time stamp in the
description if you'd like to skip this
intro my name is kirchey mungle i'm a
torontonian filmmaker with a background
in mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as analyzing consciousness and
seeing its potential connection to
fundamental reality whatever that is
essentially this channel is dedicated to
exploring the under nature of reality
the constitutional laws that govern it
provided those laws exist at all and are
even noble to us if you enjoy witnessing
and engaging with others on the topics
of psychology consciousness physics etc
the channels themes then do consider
going to the discord and the subreddit
which are linked in the description
there's also a link to the patreon that
is patreon.com
kerchamungle if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reasons that i'm
able to have podcasts of this quality
and this depth given that i can do this
now full time thanks to both the patrons
and the sponsors support speaking of
sponsors there are two the first sponsor
is brilliant during the winter break i
decided to brush up on some of the
fundamentals of physics particularly
with regard to information theory as i'd
like to interview chiara marletto on
constructor theory which is heavily
based in information theory now
information theory is predicated on
entropy at least there's a fundamental
formula for entropy so i ended up taking
the brilliant course i challenged myself
to do one lesson per day and i took the
course's random variable distributions
and knowledge slash uncertainty what i
loved is that despite knowing the
formula for entropy which is essentially
hammered into as an undergraduate it
seems like it comes down from the sky
arbitrarily and with brilliant for the
first time i was able to see how the
formula for entropy which you're seeing
right now is actually extremely natural
and it'd be strange to define it in any
other manner there are plenty of courses
and you can even learn group theory
which is what's being referenced when
you hear that the standard model is
predicated on u1 cross su-2 cross su-3
those are lead groups continuous lead
groups visit brilliant.org
tow t-o-e to get 20 off an annual
subscription and i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
you previously had a difficult time
grocking the second sponsor is algo now
algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce return and
inventory write-downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since near its inception in
fact amjad has his own podcast on ai and
consciousness and business growth and if
you'd like to support the tow podcast
then visit the link in the description
to see amjad's podcast because
subscribing to him or at least visiting
supports the toe podcast indirectly
thank you and enjoy
of all the pieces of evidence that
you've seen that you've heard of hard
pieces of evidence that you can disclose
which one stands out as most
extraordinary and why is it not ordinary
well
of the pieces that i've seen
um
you know there's the materials that have
supposedly been
dropped
uh from kraft
uh you know they're they're ordinary in
some ways but they're extraordinary from
the standpoint if you ask
why why would somebody as in the case of
the council bluffs incident why would
something drop uh some form of malton
uh metal that has iron and a few other
impurities um as opposed
to uh
anything i mean i i suppose i would say
that anything that you have which is
again
allegedly dropped off of some of these
objects
is in and of itself extraordinary
um because you have to ask the question
okay well what what is it about this
should
the event be real
uh that is somehow linked to the
formation of uh either a power supply or
a propulsion or something else i mean
for all we know it's the side product of
their entertainment system
you know
so you know you you you
when you get something like this
you would perhaps like it to be related
to
you know uh something extraordinary
about the the the craft or the object's
mobility or function but it might have a
completely uh side
use that is unrelated to any of the
above
what i find extraordinary particularly
let's say about the council bluffs is
that i know
of at least three other events that are
similar in terms of material that was
dropped and in case
one of them is here in california
uh where the i i haven't had a chance to
analyze it directly but at least
visually it's the same
so
you know when it comes to science when
you have two examples of something
similar it's
more than a coincidence
when you have those kinds of things you
know the other one that is uh
is both uh
extraordinary as well as ordinary
is the
the event uh in trinity that jacques
valet wrote about
and the uh object which was supposedly
taken you know from the from the craft
by these two children
um
that
you know i've had it here at my house
several times with jacques brings it
over and we you know we talk about it we
don't need it because it's
but it's just it's just sort of like a
a point of reference to have it here as
we're talking with a group of other
people about it
um
in that it you know for all intents and
purposes and there's pictures of it on
the web
uh for all intents and purposes it looks
very uh normal and if anything
uh
crafted in a
in a
old style way by a kind of what's called
sand casting of um of molten metal
there's a
a process it's called sand casting i
think
um
and so
you know i either it's
something which was
i mean this is uh speculation on jock's
part at some point is that
you know there was there had been an
actual object on the on the graphic by
the time the that
had been replaced by this thing for some
reason we don't know why but that when
the children came on board it had
already whatever was actually there had
already been removed and then this had
been put there it was the only thing
that they could grab and pull off so
they ran with it so it might have you
know for instance absolutely nothing to
do with the craft itself
or the object itself uh and has been
something that the the
you know for some reason the department
of defense who got there first decided
they just needed to put there as a
placeholder i i don't know
so i mean but it's extraordinary in and
of itself that somebody if they took
something off the craft the dod let's
say
there had been something there they took
something off they felt they had to
replace it with something
if that makes sense so
firstly what do you mean when you said
that we don't need it you said jack
would bring it over but you don't need
it
oh we we we don't need to have it here
every time we have a discussion about it
is what i mean
but
you know
it's just the uh the personalities
involved
like to have it almost like a
a reference point sitting in the middle
of the table as we talk about it
okay and so for those who are unfamiliar
with this story there were two children
who watched a craft crash is that
correct and then there were some beings
and then actually when i was speaking to
jacques which i called him jack before
but jacques we didn't get into what
happened to those aliens what happened
to them
well i mean if you read the book the
um
there was uh
they were observed over the course of uh
several hours as it was uh relayed by
the children um
sort of
uh
walking around outside of the craft in
in a kind of a in a tizzy essentially
frantically
yeah like
yeah
yeah and
um
so that in and of itself was was
interesting
and then they were no longer there at
some point at least when the when the um
defense department or the army people
arrived
but there was another
event because the the
the children who took
the
um the object
hid it
in a shed as i recall
on their father's property on one of
their father's property
under the floorboards and for some
reason the kids were in there at night
and this is one of the really weird
how do you
how do you put this in a materialism or
a materialistic kind of context that
they said that the
the beings whatever they were
walked through the wall
into the
into the shed and
pointed
towards where the object was
okay well that's strange right first of
all because
to me at least the object looks very
ordinary it looks like it's something
was probably
you know taken from some farm tractor or
something and
you know
uh i would love it if the people would
look online
overlaying an image you know
but no i mean you so overlay the image
yeah and
um you know can anybody identify this
you know they've been things like said
oh this is a piece of of something from
a windmill well that's that's nice
speculation but show me and i would love
for somebody to show me that that's what
it is because
again to me it looks ordinary
um but if it is ordinary then why would
the children say that later the being
seemed to come and point at it as if it
was something important
and it comes back to that thing that
both john keel and
jacques have said is that after these
events occur
there are these
reinforcement
efforts that seem to go on like like the
the men in black show up the day after
and tell you not to do so not to say
something what's going to make you
remember something more
than if somebody shows up and tells you
not to remember it
so
so again it's it's that kind of uh
strangeness associated with it that
you know many so-called skeptics
rightfully
and as jacques has said because i think
frankly he's the king of skeptics
um said this is absurd
you know how does it make sense
what do we make from something like this
so anyway that's
those are the two that that i'm most
interested in you know then i guess a
third one would be the the bismuth
material
that hal put off
talks about a lot around the wave guide
um you know i've i i've looked at it and
i have heard both sides of the argument
as to whether it's you know the
byproduct of just a normal human
smelting process versus is it something
real
i i don't know um
so i guess only further testing
will determine there's other materials
like the one from san san augustine uh
that again i have looked at now several
of them not all of them but several of
them and they're completely explainable
and we'll be
publishing some papers on those as well
uh people who think that there's
something called
alien honeycomb it's not
it's something from a 1940s
process and that's if anything a
a bit of a
that's a bit of a news release if you
will we haven't talked about that
publicly but we we know absolutely that
the so-called alien honeycomb is
not it's from a it's from a 1940s uh
standard um
aeronautics
process
do you have any biological samples in
your possession
no
i don't i don't um i was offered some
biological samples these are the some of
the so-called implants
but when i started asking questions
about the um
the provenance of these things i and the
first one was
well where
where's the consent forms from the
patient
right and um because you can't just go
running willy-nilly with pieces of
people's bodies or things out of
people's bodies that first of all don't
have consent forms
uh second of all
uh and that's for both hipaa as well as
as other reasons i'm about to tell you
which is
that
you know let's say that somebody takes a
nodule out of somebody's arm
well who's to say it's not cancer did
you send it to a pathologist for review
none of these things were done with most
of these things and i i realized that
the person who realized who took out
some of these things was themselves a
doctor
but they probably should have known
better
you know because if these days something
goes wrong and that person
gets cancer even if it wasn't that thing
wasn't cancer somebody could quite
rightly ask you
did you test that how do you know that
that wasn't uh a initiating cancer and
the person died of a metastasis
so you're at fault
so the materials that i
uh were sent was sent at one point after
i asked that question within a few days
i sent it right back
and said no
i mean would i love to be able to get a
handle on biological materials
absolutely because i can go through all
of the testing that i know how to do in
fact i'm probably better at biological
materials than i am at metals
are you able to test if it's cancer like
you are you able to test now even though
years
as long as it's been preserved i can't i
sent it back
but you know the other thing is that you
you can't
if i don't have a consent form from the
patient
and in some cases some of these let's
say objects are are so
old if you will
uh that there is no consent form and
then you'd have to go to the family
members to get consent
because the people are public
and often and the names are public
and you know the families might not want
to be besmirched so you know you just
got to be very careful with all of this
stuff
you know and i think i learned it i i
learned this uh most through the the
atacama exercise
um
that even though i didn't think it was
uh
i thought that it was probably like a
monkey or something like that when we
found out conclusively that acaba was
human
well that's when
the ethicists descended and moss
to say well we you should have known
well you didn't know first of all but
secondly um you know
there were no consents from family which
was you know that's right but you know
i i i didn't take the thing and i didn't
uh
i didn't um
know what it was at the beginning but
now people know conclusively and they
can do what they want
with that data and i think give the give
the young girl a proper
resting but that's a whole other issue
altogether but i mean it does tell you
that you know you can walk into areas
thinking you're doing good and uh you
know when you find out the truth if you
will then people will um decide based on
the truth what you should have done even
before you knew it
that's an interesting point walking into
an area thinking that you're doing good
and then realizing the truth and then
realizing you perhaps shouldn't have
walked into that to begin with there's
this question i have about when
someone's encountering the phenomenon
let's imagine this occurs to one of the
people watching
do you have advice given from all that
you know and all of the people you've
spoken to like lou for example should
someone's approach it stay away run away
i would not like someone directly
afterwards should they not wash their
clothing because that's residual
evidence on it
i see i see like a crime scene um well
first thing is i wouldn't approach it
right because you know you don't know
what it is you know just
just because you see a glowing ball of
something doesn't mean it's an alien it
could be bald lightning you know rare as
it is and that could be you know that's
a purely terrestrially explainable
phenomenon at some level and you you
might hurt yourself
so you know and then i i just wouldn't
approach it and i would save everything
that you can
um and
i think writing down your thoughts at
the moment is probably the most
important thing because remembering
things years later
you fill in the gaps
so you know
write it down but also i would also say
don't believe everything you see
right
just because you see something doesn't
mean it's
actually there
you know there's
there are enough stories about people
who feel that these things are
projections
right that uh so maybe something
projected into an individual's mind
again this is all conjecture and i again
i want to warn the various skeptics who
love to write little nasty grams about
me
um
you know i'm not
a born and true believer
i
am interested in finding out what the
truth is
about these things
i feel that given that there are enough
individuals who seem to report seeing
the same things or experiencing the same
things that there's a story here
that needs to be explained it's either
mass hysteria
some form of jungian
collective
unconscious
kind of thing or it's or it's something
real but then once you get to the it's
something real how real or unreal is it
and again if you if people are familiar
with
um john keel and jacques
uh primary theses on this
that it's
you know there's there's an element of
irre irreality to this that has yet to
be understood
it drives me crazy
you know thinking about it um
and
anybody especially with jacques
uh with the background and knowledge
about what it is that that jacques
involves himself with is he's always
looking for what's behind the what's
behind
right that what you're presented
is
um as he often has called it a form of
kabuki theater
right it's it's it's something which is
meant to be an intermediary or a
stand-in
for an
objective right that these beings or
whatever the people claim that is that
they see
aren't necessarily
the the beings or the or the
consciousness as you're interested in
that's actually driving the process that
there's something put there
in the stead of
whatever this higher level consciousness
is
as an intermediary and i had a long
discussion about this i think on the lex
friedman show for people who want to you
know talk about that the whole the the
ants and how do you communicate with
ants right right i'll leave a link to
that in the description
many of the skeptics don't unders well
maybe they understand but for this topic
they don't
they
don't seem to have a handle that science
is contingent on speculation
that it's difficult in some ways the
ground that one stands on as a scientist
because it's difficult to build up from
the atomic rational facts and that one
makes intuitive leaps and they're
inspired by logic but often in
contradiction to it and independent from
it right idea generation is throwing
plenty at the wall and noise will fail
and inventive ideas are generally seen
as outlandish nonsensical initially
anyway
one of the goals with the toe channel
with this channel is to have these
behind the door conversations that
ordinarily occur in academia to be in
front of the monitor so at some point
i'll have on carl firsten and mike 11
who are going to be speculating in real
time
in front of the audience just to show
what it looks like right well it's
absolutely true and you you call out
something and i haven't i've ever
haven't really ever put it that way um
is that the foundation of science
is
as you said pure speculation but i go
only a step further
the foundation of science is built on
fantasy
right that the
the fantasies of how we think the world
is operating
right i mean nobody would have even
and all of our science is almost two to
three thousand years old if you go back
to plato
uh and the greeks and even further back
many other cultures have all contributed
um and and yet none of them understood
that today reality is built up from
these quantum waveforms
right way down at the at the base level
of whatever it is that the universe
really is and so and yet our
our ability to talk about it is all
built on surrogate knowledge
of what is actually really operating and
only as it gets to
an observable level uh do we ever really
talk about what reality is and yet way
down deep is this complex math
that is
is still yet unexp unexplainable
and and so it's
we're building our picture of the world
on a form of a fantasy and and and
science does that
right i mean the
the um as a biologist for instance
we rarely if ever see the things
in their
native form
that we talk about inside of cells
everything is with these surrogate
measurements
i attach something to something else and
when it does this i infer that
and so we make up these ideas about how
it is that nature
is constructed
but it's rarely having seen
what it is that's there and it was
really only you know in say the last 50
or so years
with the advent of things like electron
microscopy
and uh
the determination of protein structures
and other things by by crystallography
that
our fantasies
matched a picture of the reality where
we could actually see the proteins that
we knew were there and they had the
modules and the pieces on them that we
inferred must be operable from other
genetics or other kinds of experiments
and so i think
science is moving towards a more
let's say picture-based
view of the world
but
most of our linguistics around the
discussion of science is still using
the fantasy language of 100 to 200 years
ago
so you have to but you have to come up
with crazy ideas to explain
these i mean we see it every day in my
lab you're like wait how what what's
going on here uh maybe it's this maybe
it's that and and i always tell people
that at least the way that i do it is
that your your best at science when you
can instantly formulate
a whole range
of ideas that might explain it
and everything from you know things that
are potentially real and based on the
experiments you do all the way down to
i jokingly say micro elves running the
universe
but you but you have to be able to keep
all of that in mind
at a moment and then you have to cut
kind of two threshold and in order the
most likely chain of probability that
one is correct or not and i come up with
a couple of thresholds
one threshold is
possible
and then everything below it is you know
yeah okay no there's no micro elves
running the universe um
but then
and everything above it is possible and
then within that you have to be able to
say above this is testable
and in here is this kind of no man's
land of possible
but i don't have the instrumentation yet
to test it
and actually that's the area more often
that personally i like to work
because because we
don't have the means to test something
or and then that's where for instance
i've created a number of companies and
sold them
over the years and it's always been
about
shrinking the size of the untestable
realm
so that we can basically when we come up
with a hypothesis
that's based on materialism of some sort
i can actually see it and that's moved
you know i i mean some of the
instruments in my lab were spun out as
companies and then everybody in the
world in the sciences
in my area uses them uh
and
you know but but i've been focusing
smaller and smaller and smaller down
towards subcellular and now atomic
imaging so
what do you make of the derision from
the skeptics and maybe even scientists
who say well i only follow the data and
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence what's your
response to those statements
um
well my response is well that's if
that's how you want to operate stay in
the caves
i'm interested in leaving the caves and
going out um into uncharted territory
and uh
you know the the the derision comes i
think
from people thinking that a conclusion
has been made
no conclusion has been made and explain
a potential explanation
for
the data has been offered
um and even when you publish a paper
everybody knows that when you publish a
paper and you state the conclusions
you are stating a formulation of the
observations at a moment in time
fully well realizing that 10 years from
now or 20 years from now what you
thought was x y and z
is actually part of a larger framework
in picture
that uh you can look back and say well
that's not quite the way to look at it
here's how you would think about how
this is operating
so
papers are
although people like to think are
scientists saying this is how things are
even though it comes across that way
often in papers it really is just a
moment in time
that you're planning a flag and you're
going to say okay 10 20 years from now
we might reformulate because new data
has arrived which allows us to put
things in a into a bigger picture
i mean you know this from from physics
you know maxwell's equations on
you know on electricity and uh
and magnetism
um
you know there are formulations of those
these days that
show that you know there's a form of
quantum physics that actually inc that
you can that maxwell's equations fall
out of
but it's a larger the
quantum the the quantum equations are a
larger
picture of reality and that
the maxwell's equations are just a piece
of them that fall out of it
and
and so
the critics actually don't bother me
they you know if anything they make
themselves out to be
uh you know obviously less informed
and it's not my job to convince
the critics in my opinion my job is just
to do the science and get the data out
there and say this data is real now
you help me figure out what it is that
it means
and when data comes out that shows that
something is not what they want it to be
i've i'll be right there
in fact if anything i have disproven
more things in this field
than i've been i have proven to date
you know the atacama the stark house
skull
and a couple of these uh so-called
events
it sounds like you're saying look i
haven't come to conclusions
in fact what you're doing as the
quote-unquote skeptic is coming to a
non-conclusion by saying so-and-so is
not possible or then they may modify and
say well i'm saying so-and-so is not
probable but then the way that i like to
view that is well not like to view that
there's a problem that i can't solve
which is called a reference class
problem which if anyone studies
statistics this comes up it's that how
do you know the probability of some
event so for example if i was to say
well what's the probability that you're
going to die this year and then you
could say well
well it's actually
100 it's 99
and then i say why then you say well if
you look at all the life forms on the
planet
most of them are going to die in the
next year because most of them right so
why are you choosing that as your
reference class so you'd say okay
okay okay so then when someone says well
aliens and so-and-so are now or
extraterrestrial beings or so-and-so are
not possible they're choosing from a
certain reference class and that i don't
know how one justifies that
so even claims of probability that
so-and-so is more profitable or less
probable they're dubious to me
well the the one that always gets me
that just is
shows me how some of the skeptics are
almost knee-jerk about it is this notion
that well if they came from another star
system
um it would have taken them thousands of
years to get here
all right well okay i have two solutions
to that one it's a very old universe
um
two
uh well and in that there's plenty of
time for somebody have to have come here
even by simply conventional means and
that doesn't mean that
the people who created the craft
that got here are the ones that are here
you know if you're advanced enough to be
able to create your own ai
right i mean there's the whole concept
of the von neumann machines you know
this one right the von neumann machine
idea
that you know something arrives makes
more copies of itself
sends those copies off elsewhere and
basically there's this exponential uh
reach
even across you know across galaxies
and what's to say that when such an
object arrives it doesn't construct from
base
processes
uh an egg
that then is then turned into uh
whatever it is that the von neumann
machine is meant to make and then
you know i mean there have been plenty
of science fiction stories written about
this
that and when they get there the ai then
teaches the humans what it is to be a
human
right there's um there's actually one
that's just on netflix right now raised
by wolves
uh it's a british show i think
um it's pretty good
so i mean that's that's one of them and
then second
it it assumes that we know everything
about the laws of physics
right this notion that okay well they
are somehow
as you in your terminology they are
bound by our reference frame
and uh
that our our reference is
uh the current laws of understanding of
you know e equals m c squared
uh and you know whatever somebody else
has different math
right and so if one was going by
if one was choosing the reference class
to be well look every 60 years or so in
physics our formulation of physics is
drastically overturned or let's say
every 80 years yeah so then and we're
assuming these beings if they're beings
are far greater than 80 years ahead of
us well
right we impose that they have the same
understanding of physics
also it's false to say that from the
nearest star system it takes thousands
of years to come to us they can come to
us or someone can come to us with
special relativity almost
instantaneously it's just that thousands
of as far as they're concerned yeah
right right in their reference frame
right
in december of in a few months ago
december 2021 diana posalka said on
calling all beings that it's a podcast
which i'll leave a link to that in the
description that you wanted to create a
drug that interfaces with the phenomenon
on our terms
what was she referring to
um i think she was referring to some
comments i had made about
you know my frustration
listening to experiencers
uh and actually having some experiences
in in my immediate family
um
who
[Music]
had no control over
the events that were occurring to them
um
and you know there's many many many
examples of this in the literature
uh and i i
if you imagine that whatever this
is
has to
communicate with humans through
somehow our sensory apparatus in our
brain
whether it's
you know directly
if it's sound based well then there's no
drug for that but if it's somehow coming
inside
through
the sensory apparatus i used the term
telefactoring
before
that
if it's interfering with us in some way
why couldn't we make if we understand
enough about how the interference is
being generated
maybe there's a drug to stop us
or to prevent that from occurring you'd
i mean there's a lot of science that
have to be done around something like
that and i'm not saying
it's doable tomorrow or
anything like that
uh but
um
the the notion is for the people who
feel that they are
being
inappropriately
interacted with give them the ability to
turn it off you know it makes you wonder
sometimes again this pure speculation
makes you wonder sometimes whether
people who are in mental health
facilities
today
so-called schizophrenics or what have
you
um who
can't seem to function properly in
normal society
how many of them have such
again speculation
have these continued interactions they
just can't turn them off it would drive
you crazy if some if you constantly
heard something in your head
i i just bought a t-shirt by the way
that's really fun i found it online
it said the voices are back
excellent
that's freaky well i had some experience
i won't go into it here and it's not a
phenomena well maybe i don't think it's
a phenomenon experience where i had to
go to the i had to send myself to the
hospital because i was typing and then i
wasn't typing and something said to me
yeah you're you thought you were the one
that was in control and it was using my
fingers whatever it was and i was
freaking the heck and then it said maybe
the crazy ones aren't crazy
inferring implying sorry that so that
that happened to you yeah yeah and that
was and and i was
i
i like even talking about it now works
me up a bit so anyway i called the the
hospital just to say you have to come
get me because i don't know what i'm
going to do i'm not suicidal in the
least but i don't know like
why why would i and anyway i went
downstairs i remember the police came
first and i told the police officer i'm
not going to try and grab your gun which
already freaks the police officer up and
i'm like right i don't know what i'm
like i'm i'm extremely scared right now
so please just just treat me calmly and
nicely because i'm in a sensitive state
right now and then they just looked at
me like okay all right let's let's just
wait until the
to the right let's get to
the paramedics come yeah and since then
i i almost never use the word crazy to
refer to someone yeah i think that
that's a word of condescension and it
also automatically and autumn it also
implies that one has that their frame is
the correct frame and then it also
triggers me i'm hypersensitive to this
to think about what the heck is reality
and for this line of work that i'm doing
right now
that's all i do and so i've had to
actually
stop studying consciousness for a little
while because it was putting me into an
extremely horrible horrible horrible
state and i think that anyone who thinks
about consciousness or ufos even or the
phenomena and takes it seriously that i
don't know how they don't send
themselves into a a spiral of yeah an
unhealthy spiral well i think that's a
really interesting point because
you know i i have again some friends who
are who get so deeply into this that
they do i worry sometimes if they're not
just
you know
creating a a mental world for themselves
of of true fantasy
and so sometimes just get back out into
the real world
um and again don't
don't
don't
follow it
down the rabbit hole uh because you can
very easily
as you say uh you can you can create the
problem for yourself that has
it's only going on in your head
um
you know i i had i'll just say this this
is something i haven't talked about ever
publicly before i had an experience in
london once
um
that
i still don't understand to this day it
was like you know
i don't know why this always happens at
three o'clock in the morning
it's hilarious but
for a lot of people um
and i woke up and my whole body was just
pulsing
and with like some sort of electric fire
like nothing i'd ever felt before
um
and it
feel it and but hear it hear it and feel
it from the tip of my toes to my fingers
whole body um
and right as i woke up
it wasn't even words it was more like a
but it was clear it was
the words
this is how you connect
and it went on for about 15 seconds
and then i just said whatever stop this
has got to stop
and
and and it and it stopped
so i was clearly awake i had control
over it
but again this where did this voice come
from i mean maybe it was a dream
you know the voice was a dream voice of
some sort but the feeling was not i'd
never had any feeling like that before
um and uh interestingly the next evening
it happened again at about the same time
but only a very fractional
um
sense of it
you know so i asked actually i came back
and i asked jack said what what what
could that have been and he said well
maybe it was a kundalini event or
something less i went right about
kundalini never heard of it before uh it
didn't seem to match any of that
um but it was it was
an experience if you will that i can't
explain might be have a completely
normal physiologic basis i spoke to i
mean my next-door neighbor is the
chairman of psychiatry at stanford and
so she sees everything
um and i spoke with her
yes he's useful and uh
and uh so
uh she says no that doesn't fall into
any of the frameworks of things that we
hear about
that's not what you want to hear exactly
i was like damn i just i maybe you just
told me i ate too much indian food or
something
which i do when i go to london a lot
first thing i do is i head to the i head
to the indian restaurants um and so you
should ask them
yeah
well they might have a different
explanation for it right i mean you know
the the the mystics and and
yogis of india i think are at the at the
root of many of these um
uh i don't know the these stories
they're they're probably the most
sophisticated i would say of the shamans
who have explored uh
uh you know that in in an almost
scientific manner
have you found that any of the people
who have experienced the phenomena
recall people who are familiar with you
know about the caudate and the putamen
and there's certain connections
okay that
that to me implies that for the people
who don't have those connections if they
were standing next to the other
people that they wouldn't experience the
phenomena if it was purely some
projection that only right class of
people right have you heard of cases
like that yes yeah yeah i mean jacques
will
probably be the better person to
talk to about it because he knows them
specifically but yeah there's there's
several cases where people will see
something that the other person doesn't
um and actually let me tell you talk a
little bit about that about that caudate
thing
um because
you know we've now we've published one
paper with the group at harvard and
we've got another one that is coming out
uh that once again
uh the caudate pataman basal ganglia is
at the core
of uh many of the
let's say the more mainstream things
that we were claiming even before we had
our first publication that the caudate
is the basically is a central node
involved in intuitive and uh other um
well crystallized
and um fluid intelligence
and so even though kit and i had sort of
come to this conclusion that it was
involved with intuition and we intuited
it that it was involved with intuition
when you dive into the literature
you find
we found easily now dozens of papers
that others have done from completely
mainstream points of view that show the
caudate is
key
to i mean this tiny little thing inside
of your brain this giant brain and this
key little thing in the in the center is
sort of like the node
what we've also done now is we've been
doing uh
what you would call morphometrics
so we've taken the mris of people's
brains
we've uh basically you can use that to
basically
circle the areas of the brain that
people have recognized before here's the
thalamus
pataman you know all these various
parts of the brain
um we can get the size the volume the
densities we can even get with the right
uh kind of mri you can get what's called
tensorflow which is really uh the the
the tracts between brain regions that
are uh basically the cables that connect
the various regions
and because we we
you know in biology that there's that
there's always a give and take across a
system right that if one thing is is
doing something and it's it's bigger
because of it there'll be a compensation
elsewhere in the system and that it's
the parts all playing together
that create the function
no
any one point might be a node that's key
uh for let's say uh driving the process
overall but there's no one thing alone
and so using this notion of networks
we've now been able to see show that
well it's not just the caudate there's
an area over here that when this is
large or small
this compensates
so a person
you know this focus only on the caudate
is again this is now a reinterpretation
of a flag in the sand because of what we
could do four years ago versus what we
can do today
now today
we can look at the whole brain
automate what we call the segmentation
of the of the brain
and um then run
so um when kit did the analysis
originally he did it by hand and he did
it double blinded with another um with
another uh forensic pathologist
a neurophysiology forensic pathologist
um and he basically said okay well
here's the area that has the higher
density
um and he basically like it it's hard
enough to figure out what the area in 2d
is
uh but to basically do that in 3d you
know on a computer screen where you're
drawing volumes and
things
that's that's a very manual process
and obviously going to be subject to
bias
right and so you try to know
you you make sure that the person who's
doing the measurements doesn't know what
it is that they're measuring in other
words are they from a control group or
are they from the experiencer or high
functioning group that you think so you
want to take the person out
so then we built artificial intelligence
uh algorithms
that uh would basically scan the brain
find the volumes
segment means draw a circle around
them and i have experience with this in
our cancer work where we do this kind of
segmentation all the time in 2d one of
my companies two of my companies
actually are
you know basically
create biopsy images with a kind of
biological depth that allows us to do
segmentation of the cells and into
regions and neighborhoods and things so
we're taking the same thing now up to 3d
um
so automate the segmentation means now
we can basically take 200 patients
run it in the program overnight
and get all the segmentation volumes out
the next day
i mean previously it took kit and his
you know his colleague
something like a year
to do that
are you able to do that with the data
that you have before or you need to
rescan people in some new manner yeah we
the um the data that we had before
and because of the havana syndrome
um
let's say
diagnoses of some of these individuals
it complicates first of all the cohort
second the i i don't have access to
those mris anymore um because once it
started to become clear that this was
going to be an important problem
uh basically kit
uh put a lockdown on it because because
me even getting access to these many of
these patients
and rightly so
because some of the patients were public
and
some of those patients
didn't like the fact that we were
talking about
their uh or as it turned out even though
they had given us verbal permission to
study it and talk a little bit about it
they didn't want to be grouped
with you know either the havana syndrome
or other classifications
and so
uh i don't want to touch them anymore
right and
no no no because let's say that you are
publicly known
as being such an individual
right maybe as being part of the class
and then i make some statement about
that
like i make the statement oh and so many
people might be crazy well you know i
mean first of all i wouldn't say that
but second of all
um second of all
they will feel painted by that brush
uh so when you're talking about humans
and people
you know
they're not data points they're people
with feelings
and um and feelings that can be very
easily hurt
and if you are in any way known
for you know having been an experiencer
all it takes is one person tweeting out
your name
and saying you're this or you're that
and you know you can more than just ruin
somebody's day
and so in the current social media
environment
uh you have to go with entirely
anonymized data
uh which is but when that's the reason
why we i turned to this group at harvard
um
because you know they
had access to the a lot of the databases
and they had the interest
in the use of mris for these kinds of
you know more or less say mainstream
studies and so the first paper that we
did
uh we
um
we looked at schizophrenics and autism
individuals because you know on the far
end in the positive in the fully
positive sense of schizophrenics
is that often they can be very creative
individuals
because their minds let's say range a
little bit further
than than than others they see or make
connections that others don't that
others don't exactly and that's really
the heart of intuition
you know finding disparate datas and
showing that they actually have a hidden
connection behind the scenes
um
and then on the other side of the
of the um let's say problem are autistic
spectral disorder of which there are
many different types of of um autism
but
certain
autistics as you probably know can be
extremely high functioning and they have
again
almost
not a form of intuition
like they're oh i i i see things that
other people don't it's they can come to
conclusions that are remarkable like
mathematical conclusions
all right p people who are you know you
can ask them what the square root of
some extraordinary number is
and they go like that how how where and
why how do they do that what's the
process in their brain that allows them
to do that so as it turns out that if
you look at the mris of such individuals
one of the areas of the brain that's
called out
repeatedly in both of them but in
different places
is the caudate containment there are
what we would call at least from our
let's say normative standpoint
uh defects
in their caudate potamin you know not
like wholesale rupturing or anything
like that but
you know smaller regions or things that
seem to be have gone wrong
um so it's the diminution of the caudate
putainum or is it or just just no
neither just kind of let's say
dysmorphias
this morphe is just kind of like changes
and
um you know and and in in one sense if
it's any of these things and i don't
know that all of them or any of them are
which of them are if it's genetically
determined
it's evolution
trying out something new
because if it were a successful
mutation
that helped both that individual and
their let's say uh genetically related
group uh succeed or compete better than
others it will be over the course of
time selected for
um and uh in a positive in a positive
sense so anyway we we have these these
groups and the reason we were doing this
is we wanted
to at least as i've been framing it
you know
if so-called experiences have these
experiences
do their brains look normal
do their brains look more like
schizophrenics
or do their brains look more like
autistics because one of the things that
you as a skeptic or as a doctor might do
is
if i say you know if you kurt you know
repeatedly say there's somebody typing
through my fingers
um the doctor you know the you're a
psychiatrist interviewing you would want
to say you know whether or not this
person is showing signs of some sort of
dissociative disorder
well
we would like someday to be able to look
in a person's brain
from a purely pathology standpoint and
say with an mri ah their brain structure
has elements of
schizophrenia
or my child we is not talking as much as
they think we think he might be autistic
so you get an mri done and you say oh
yes they do actually have a brain
structure which is consistent with an
autistic
right so
you know
i want to exclude that class from the
people who are experienced no i i i
don't i don't want to exclude them but i
want to i mean it it would be nice to
know if experiencers fall on
that
spectrum
or a different spectrum altogether right
so our schizophrenic somehow opposite to
autistics no no no no uh
good question as i said it i realized it
was
it was so there's a spectrum between
normal and autistics
and then there's a spectrum between
normal and schizophrenics in terms of
behaviors
right and so
from a materialist standpoint you like
you people like to somehow think is that
there's going to be a brain structure
which is
correlated with this if not even a brain
structure let's say just a metabolism of
how the brain operates i mean you could
have i can have a normal brain and then
something can go wrong with my with my
metabolism and that could that could
mimic
uh a pathology that might be
um that might be tissue based so there's
tissue based mythologies and then
there's and then there's
metabolism-based pathologies
right
you know i mean so you just think about
it like this like your kidney a person
could be born with a kidney that is for
whatever reason
uh you know
messed up right just not formed
correctly
um and then they won't have a kidney
function right at least one of the two
will not be functional correctly
and then later on in life though you
could be a normal individual
two perfectly functioning kidneys and
you know you eat
some
mushroom you shouldn't have eaten
you know made its way into your soup and
you have you know it kills off part of
your kidney your metabolism problem
right so but it could mimic the same
thing at the end
at
the end of the day your kidney's not
functioning
right and so this you know the brain is
much more complex than that
but um
so
but i so i wanted these
reference sets
so that when we ever and i'm not sure
we're ever going to do it in the in the
short term when we get around to doing
this with experiencers or frankly
different classes of
individuals with
different kinds of
extraordinary mental abilities and by
this i mean things like math or
you know uh
music or etc
you know are there brain structures
associated with these you know high
functioning individuals
that you can call out
because that tells us
it's not because you want to know what
your child is the day they're born are
they going to be a musician or a
mathematician
um
but
you by doing this begin to learn about
how the brain is actually functioning
so that
with these now what are public data sets
that you can download off the net that
have been vetted
people have been classified according to
their intellectual capabilities etc now
you can begin to show that certain and
this is one of the papers that we're
just submitting
um that certain brain structure
organization sizes and tracts between
them are
appear to be correlated with certain
kinds of intelligence or certain kinds
of uh
abilities
um
and you know we're not the only ones
doing it by not by far
but um i haven't seen many papers yet
that are taking it the same approach
that we are with these automated
um segmentations but you know it's so
easy to do
uh that i expect there to be an
explosion of research in this area
um
because it's going to tell us something
about how the brain is operating so to
circle back to your diana pasulka
question about the drug
if there is
a tract between one part of a brain and
another that seems to be important for a
certain function you know with
enough analysis maybe there's a way we
can target that area
to compensate for either a lack
or if you
find out that one part of the brain
is uh
is overworking itself which is
suppressing some other
function or maybe you turn this one off
so you either turn one on or you turn
one off
and you can either do it with a drug
drugs are harder to do because brain
chemistry as you probably know is is
really messy
and uh you know a lot of the
antidepressants that people use etc you
have to sort of try one out and they
does this one work does that one work
um but maybe transcranial stimulation
is something that might you know be
effective
uh to you know enhance certain abilities
or to turn off certain other areas
i mean another example is um
you know what's called the default mode
network in your brain but the default
mode is sort of the the organizing
principle that keeps all of the other
parts of the brain uh playing together
well
and it sits somewhere close to so-called
executive function
um well drugs like psychedelics
it looks like turn off the default mode
network and allow all of the other parts
of the brain
to
to come
you know rise to the surface and start
having a discussion
so
you know maybe the default node
mode network
turn off was what happened when you were
typing
your fingers that somehow because you
were so into what you were doing the
default node turned off and other parts
of your brain
that
you know let's say have some ass who
have who have access to
your personality
told you i'm in control now
right and maybe when i woke up that
night in
london
it was my default mode network was off
and some other part of my brain said i'm
gonna do this to you right or this is
you know so you you always have to keep
those kinds of things in the back of
your mind as possible explanations and
not always think of it as an outside
agency
that is imposing itself on you
standard psychiatry would like to
keep everything in your head
and not think of outside agencies
um and uh you know and i think probably
99 of the time it is internal
but
99 still leaves one percent
and uh external possibilities so you
know you just gotta
you just gotta keep it in mind
i mean i was
i i i was i was i don't know why on
netflix or something i was watching the
other night some guy tyler henry he's a
medium you should go look him up uh he's
it's extraordinary what he what he does
i won't relay at all but i mean i sit
there going where's this guy getting
this information he sits down across
from somebody and now he's telling them
about their life and somebody close to
them who died and giving them
information that's clearly having an
emotional impact on them
and assuming it's not all a big hoax
yeah not cold reading
it's yeah it's a kind of a cold reading
yeah it is and
and
where is he getting this information
from
right i mean it's it's
and he has a process and his process is
basically scribbling on a book
um
and it's almost as if by the scribbling
process he's
he's it's kind of a meditation he's like
he he's turning something off
and that allows other things to other
information
for him to be able to access i would
love
to get a hold of people like that
uh get mris of their brains as they're
doing these things functional mris first
of all just to see what structure do
they have
you know do they do do mediums let's say
or claimed mediums has that ever been
done as far as you know no of course no
never why do you think that is because
that as you say it sounds like an
extremely interesting study that i'm
wondering why has that not um i mean i
think people no i know of a guy in la in
fact i spoke to them
who funds
who's funding some of this kind of
research
but again nobody has had the automated
segmentation algorithms to do this and
again it's not because i don't think
people wanted to do it it's just because
again the compute power wasn't there
before i mean the kind of stuff that i
do only in 2d couldn't be done before if
with uh my pathology cancer research
because the compute power wasn't there
first of all we couldn't get the data
and second even if we had the data we
wouldn't be able to do anything with it
um but now we have the compute power to
to do it so
uh that opens new doors
and again you you should expect a huge
flow but but before one runs to try to
hit the ball out of the park
you have to do the ground work and
saying what is normal
right what's the normal range of human
brain
shapes and even amongst normals or let's
say non-uh non-mediums non well
non-classified as schizophrenic or
autistic or you know name 10 other
mental mental health issues
you know
what is
you know you you want to find out what
the main classes
of
pathologies
again i'm not i
again not using the term saying people
have a problem with this
um
before you start running into doing
mediums
right you can do it but then you have no
reference set
nobody can
nobody to compare them against to say oh
it's like this or it's like that or it
it it is this and this is different
than normal
so you know that leg work that we're
doing now is setting up for you know a
few years from now when both monies will
be available i think
even if i have to fund it myself
um or uh or you know government funding
but sometimes you will can get
government funding
by
doing something which is
let's say normal and mainstream
mental health studies
and then once you've done that
then it's possible to say mediums
i'm going to do people who have let's
say intuition and you call it intuition
right you know a study on intuition and
then amongst the cohort you you do this
it's not that you're
it's not that you're doing something
inappropriate
you're just defining it in a way frankly
that normal
scientists would
they would say oh these mediums are
picking up pumps they're intuiting
something from the environment
fine
maybe they are
right you know uh
then
let's figure out what it is that's
special about their ability to do it it
might have no paranormal aspect to it
whatsoever
i still would want to know how this guy
does it
is this to be taken as a call for people
who are mediums to email you or no no my
god no no i get enough as it is i'm at
some point
yes
but at some point short in the short
term no i'm not ready for it
at all and i don't even know that i'm
the right person to do it there's i have
been contacted by a few scientists who
want to do it and then they would want
access to these databases at that point
but no i have enough to do
earlier you mentioned havana syndrome
and when i looked into it i found it to
be terribly murky i don't know what
havana syndrome is and so when you're
this is in reference to my research on
you with regard to skinwalker and then
you said that well we can classify some
people savannah syndrome i want to know
firstly what is venice syndrome how do
are you able to classify them as that it
seems like a cloudy definition and then
also
you concluded that some of if not all of
what was happening at skinwalker from
what you've studied with state actors so
i don't know what is meant by state
actors and how you came to that
conclusion so there are a couple of
questions right there yeah so um okay so
um
right so this all started of course with
uh with kit
uh and you know there's he's actually
given a uh an interview i think it was
on the debrief or somewhere recently uh
that's very in-depth about um
sort of the history of the of the
project and the timeline
um
so
when we first were looking at these
patients that
we got this basically a bucket of cases
um
from the
basically the defense uh intelligence
axis
that the doctors didn't know what to do
with people who were
in distress nobody would nobody could
figure out what it is that was going
wrong with them and so kit at some point
was called in on on some of them um
so
the the reason why many of these cases
are murky
and is actually hidden
in a way in the term syndrome
a a syndrome is usually a
medical terminology for something which
has
uh that has related
but disparate symptomologies
so usually it's like there's 20 things
that can fall within this classification
system you're hearing buzzing headaches
this and that
and you don't have to have all of them
you just have to have enough of them
and you say you've got this syndrome we
don't but usually what people are
thinking when they say syndrome is that
there's probably multiple different
uh sub pathologies within them each of
which is a distinct and unique group so
for instance a hundred years ago or even
80 years ago
you could have cancer
and cancer broadly
is
a you know is actually
has about you know 200 different
diseases underneath it
all right blood cancer you know calling
et cetera et cetera
so
um we actually in the by around 2015
2016 we're calling it what we called at
the time or i should say kit uh
interference syndrome
that people were being interfered with
uh and here were the range of
things that were
happening
to them
uh
and so what as a doctor you do
you basically you start to
determine what the individual symptoms
are
and those individual symptoms then are
matched to definitions
in what's the best way to do it is
called the icd codes
right and so um
the icd codes are classification
system of diseases
and related health problems right so you
have you have this kind of a skin uh
blistering uh it's you know and it has
these you know it has infiltration of
macrophages and this and this it's icd
code x
and so what you what he does is he he
takes the the the verbal testimony or
his observations of the patient
and you know writes down these icd codes
and it's a way of just classifying and
knowing that you're talking about apples
to apples oranges to oranges
kind of a thing
and then right around 2018 or so the
so-called havana cases were coming up
which were
which havana cuba specifically some of
the diplomatic personnel were having
these buzzing sounds getting sick
headaches
etc
and uh
and that kind of went public and then
kit got a hold of some of the case files
related to to these some of these events
and realized that the the when he
matched the icd codes
of the havana syndrome they matched or
overlapped with a lot of our cases
right um
and then uh
after that
um i'm gonna put you uh
a thing here somebody actually put it in
twitter somewhere to remind me of it um
a uh
a science
group the so-called jasons which are a
group of you know scientists who the
government calls upon i'm not part of
the jason's
uh to um help them
uh understand
the
um
you know some event that occurs and
write white papers and things like that
uh they were brought in to basically do
an assessment
uh of this and it became um
uh
obvious that
these cases were
probably
driven
by some
i use the term state actor some people
got bent out of shape because i used
that term i just meant what yeah what
does it mean
it basically means you know
somebody who is an agent of let's say
russia or china or something like that
or a rogue element within our own
government or frankly you know i mean
state actor implies some sort of uh
you know funded by
uh a
government um
but it could just as easily be
you know
terrorist groups
who gained acts who gained access to
um
you know some of these technologies that
could cause these things and if you look
at that
pdf that i just sent you there's
uh all kinds of different approaches
acoustic attacks electromagnetic attacks
uh microwaves i'll include a link to
that in the description as well yeah um
and uh so it's it's not it's not beyond
the capability of anybody in the last 20
years
to have these kinds of
attack
uh
you know approaches vectors or whatever
um so
so when i say it's out of my hands
uh when it's it's it's that well these
are clearly falling under
a
um
a uh
what's the right word um is falling
under the rubric or an umbrella of
something which appears to be purely
human or terrestrial yeah with intention
with intention and has nothing to do
with uaps whatsoever now what's
interesting is and this is what whoever
it was who tweeted this
recently
um
i haven't found the number in here i'm
to have to go in but they said about 10
to 15 of the cases uh that the jason's
had looked at could not be explained
under the rubric of havana syndrome and
were as a as of yet
um on
of indeterminate causation
that doesn't mean that they're uap
right it just means that again the the
broad bucket of
people with strange things happening to
them
uh didn't fall under that now
there's already people out there trying
to pick apart
the things that lou has been talking
about with injury and the things that
kit talked about as injury actually i
actually spoke with lou about it um the
other day some of the cases that lou was
talking about are different
than the um ones that uh kid are talking
about so just because kit says
it's you know he's got them all figured
out um
and uh it doesn't mean that there aren't
other cases out there that lou is aware
of
that are different than the ones that
kit is that have a much more proximal
let's say
uap relationship
uh but even kit and i talk with him
about it uh
fairly
frequently um
is like well look i can explain it by
human technology
i don't need to invoke
something else
right
but he's very careful in how he parses
his word i can explain it
doesn't say it was caused by
human technology you know at the end of
the day a burn is a burn whether it's
caused by
you know
an alien power generator or
you know the back end of a jet flame
right um so
you know he's just saying i don't need
the the fact that these injuries occur
does is not a smoking gun
for uap
so you know he's being a good scientist
about it
but the the only thing that you have to
sort of walk away from with it is some
of the people say
that the proximal cause
was an object that showed up
it wasn't they were working in their
office at the you know at the havana you
know american
embassy and they got headaches you know
these were people who were in the field
who saw something and something happened
to them the cash laundromat case is
probably one of the best
in
cases in point
i went through this recently released
dirt document from 2009 the dirt
document that i'm referencing is called
the defense intelligence reference
document it's titled anomalous acute and
subacute field effects on human
biological tissues you can find a link
to it in the description
i went through this recently released
dirt document from 2009 i went through
it not with a fine-tooth comb with a
regular comb let's say
i skimmed it and i want to read a
passage to you and i want to know what
you make of it it said based on
historical cases humans have been found
to be injured from the exposures to
anomalous vehicles especially airborne
and when in relatively close proximity
and then i said okay especially airborne
which to me implies that there are some
non-airborne cases so what are these
non-airborne type vehicles and what's
the difference between the effects on
the witnesses from non-airborne versus
airborne uh i i don't know the specifics
that are being discussed there um you
know
non-airborne i don't know maybe it's the
thing is landed
i i don't know i don't know the
individual cases unfortunately
um
and uh
again it's um
i i can't pry them out of out of kit
for good reason
uh
for all the reasons that you you know he
just he just can't let these cases out
it doesn't have anything to do with uap
it's just i i i couldn't force this
stuff
i i can't force the information out of
some of the cancer patients from the
cancer patients that the doctors i work
with because they're rightly protecting
their privacy
you know people have great questions but
they think
they think that uh
we can just play
you know willy-nilly with people's
private data you can't and it is i'm not
hiding behind it i'm telling you as much
as what i know
but um at the end of the day the
specifics
uh will remain
you know uh out of reach
uh i think the
what people should take away from it is
that it's it's reason to attempt to fund
true research
what we would call prospective
research
uh prepare to collect the data
in you know in a going forward manner as
opposed to retrospective analysis of old
cases where you're you're trying to
piece together something that happened
in the distant past
you prefer perspective i prefer
perspective now retrospective i mean we
do retrospective studies all the time on
cancer you know we with a large enough
cohort of individuals of colorectal
cancer for instance we can use
you know biological analyses of the of
the tissue and find signatures of
outcome
right because retrospective we know what
the we know what the
disease was we know what the drug that
they were given and we know what the
outcome was for those patients and so
now what you're doing is you're looking
amongst the patients who had a good
outcome versus those that had a bad
outcome and saying was there a was there
a tissue structure that predicted the
good outcome or the bad outcome because
that tissue structure was going to be
susceptible to the drug
right to make the drug be more likely to
operate and work than not
and so that's just that's how these
prospective
now a prospective study would be i'm
setting up to do this and i'm going to
collect the data knowingly and i'm going
to create inclusion exclusion criteria
that bring the right kinds of patients
in and then i so i know i'm working with
apples and apples
right so
you work with retrospective usually to
form hypotheses
interesting of what it is that you want
to do and then you prove the
retrospective
conclusions
uh with a prospective new study that's
tailored specifically to look at the
things that you think
are important
are there any retrospective or
prospective
studies
that you know about on psychedelics and
ufos or psychedelics potentially
summoning certain beings via some
meditative technique
so i again i was talking to this this
group in la that are doing they're
serious scientists
that have um a potentially wealthy
benefactor to to do just this i mean i'm
not doing the study with them they just
called me to get my perspective
on it um and so i hope that they
go ahead and and do it because
you know there's there's lots of people
willing to partake in those kinds of
studies uh there's frankly no nih
program that's ever going to be funded
in the near future
for for doing this kind of stuff for all
the reasons we know
um so
you know the uh a wealthy and interested
benefactor
um
is really the next best thing
for that
do psychedelics have any role to play in
the caudate putiman connection
and by the way is this a red herring
because earlier you mentioned well just
because it's overgrown here it could
imply a lesser growth somewhere else
yeah that could be what's actually worth
that could be
yeah i mean or it could limit i mean if
you're you know if you it's like a fuel
injector um
uh
you know if you if you limit the amount
of fuel going into one part of the brain
uh then doesn't matter how good the
upstream process is if there's a
filter it never makes it you know the
rest of the way
um now
where and how the uh
let's say dmt or these other
psychedelics operate and what they do to
the to the brain i i haven't seen
anything yet on it
um the problem is that these are of
course almost all
you know uh scheduled drugs meaning they
have limitations on their uses
and i do know of there's a guy at
stanford and there's a guy i think at
johns hopkins again i was asking my um
my uh
um psychiatry chair neighbor about this
for exactly the reasons you're asking
you know who's doing these studies right
now
um and uh the guy in la uh is actually a
very well-known doctor uh in this area
uh so he's associated with the program
with that program that they're trying to
run uh and um i think the brain
morphometry tools that we're building
will be useful to these individuals and
the data sets that we're producing will
be useful to these individuals
um and how dmt or you know psilocybin or
you know lsd uh
work into it i i don't know
um so but i'll be fascinated to see the
results
do you surmise that psychedelics are
acting as a removal of filters and
allowing in senses sorry and allowing in
sensory information absolutely yeah okay
and then it seems to me to be a
component of one generating it from
within one's own mind and then there is
possibly the other element of one
allowing in information that wouldn't
allow and then they have to mingle in
some manner right right yeah i mean i've
said this before that whatever people
think
electrosensory
uh extra sensory perception might be
um
whether it's real or not and
uh
it has to overlay
it eventually wherever the information
comes in
it has to overlay onto the normal or it
seems to be overlaying onto the normal
senses right people see things or they
hear things or they feel something emote
emotionally
um or some mixture of the of the above
so
you know you you have an internal screen
in your head you can close your eyes and
you can see things
when you dream you see it
in even more
stark clarity
so
whatever the so-called antenna might be
it is
it somehow
sits on top of
the sensory system that you already have
and
overlays the information into that if
we are purely materialistic beings now
you can start asking questions about
consciousness
maybe it has nothing to do with the
brain at all but wherever our
consciousness resides out there in
the 23rd dimension or whatever
um that all the information is going on
back there all the passage of
information is going on back there
and then
it's basically
moving it back down into the neurons
and so we might never find the antenna
because the antenna actually sits out
there
maybe the ant maybe consciousness
there's a great physicist i think i have
i should find his
stuart hammer off
no no it's a different he's a he's a
german physicist from the 1950s 60s or
so he came up with this physics of um
you know one of these grand theories of
of physics
and basically
uh he he's not well accepted by many
people but he's still followed by some
this notion that
that structures of physicality can be
created that he he basically said that
at a certain level of complexity of a
structure that's formed you can
instantiate
a um a self-perpetuating
object an entity that he said is
for all intents and purposes
consciousness or the soul
so that you know his
theory his hypothesis his premise was
basically that
evolution
and brain structure etc the purpose of
it was to basically create the flowering
of an object that he would call
consciousness that could then exist
independently
of the object that created it
it's sort of like was the that the the
body is a birth is a birth vessel for
the formation and he said at least i
mean there's lots of you know uh
spirituality uh you know religions and
things that talk about this notion from
a purely less a spiritual standpoint he
was trying to give
well he wasn't trying to
he was basically giving a physical
a physics definition of how it would
occur and he wasn't looking for it
he just as he was looking at the
equations said this is something that
falls out of it
interesting
while gary is going to get the book off
air i asked gary about the connection
between blood types and the phenomenon
and he said there is none as far as he
can tell we also weren't able to get
into meditation and the phenomenon on
air so we'll save it for next time if
you're interested in someone who
investigates uaps and is an experienced
buddhist meditator then i recommend you
visit christina gomez's youtube channel
there's a link in the description
yeah this is something that uh
jacques gave me
i just had lunch with him yesterday up
at his house and he's got these book
collections sitting around him and i
just get this lust in my heart for the
book collection
um so anyway uh
this is ludwig ludwiger
uh illa brand von ludwiger um and uh
i mean i don't understand the math i
don't even pretend to
uh but um
is he still alive as far as you know no
i think he's dead
but um
[Music]
so basically this is like almost this is
the end and i don't well according to
his theory he's not dead but
yeah according to but basically this
structure that he draws here at the end
is uh a visual representation of um
of how when
a certain structure is created
uh at the top of it
through these levels of organization
consciousness would form because of it
um and
uh
that then you could take away the
underlying structure
uh
formed it and then this would continue
to exist
okay
independently
um which is interesting the reason why i
like this and he didn't really talk
about this he talks about it in the
context of um
of uh of biology but
if it's right it means you could create
an artificial intelligence which was in
and of itself
would could become conscious
you know most
um
you know scientists working in ai never
think that we will have
the ability to create a conscious i mean
that anything that we create
uh that looks conscious is just a a darn
good simulation
of
of uh you know it would pass the turing
test
but it would just be a darn good
simulation
uh
but it's not really conscious
um
so you know it so therefore it has no
rights
as far as human rights as far as where
you know it's a big argument that's been
played out in science fiction for for
many years
what this guy is basically saying
and i don't know anything about the math
i just find it interesting i get
interested in these kinds of ideas yeah
that you could create an object
humans might someday be able to
without using biology but using purely
materialistic
uh
approaches
build a sufficiently complex machine
that creates
an object with consciousness and a soul
that's fascinating
you know so he is
go ahead did he say whether or not this
soul would survive
for an indeterminate amount of time yes
yes yes but yeah that's what he's saying
yeah take away the you can take away the
thing that caused it and it lives unto
itself
no now a lot of the reason i'm asking
about the time aspect is because like
imagine a flower then it gives rise to
some pollen well that pollen lives
independent of the flower but the pollen
also at some point dies so i'm one right
okay just because it gives birth it
doesn't mean that it's in depth yeah no
it doesn't mean it's indefinite it means
it needs a certain structure to
to create that
okay
you know i mean
read his the the the piece it's uh yeah
i'll send you a copy of it if you want
please please yeah
it's fascinating again i don't know the
math and a lot of
a lot of physicists
just
dismiss him outright
but as with any of these uh theories
there's a little often cult-like
following of people who you know are
absolutely determined to prove that he's
right in fact the the the piece is
written by somebody else is writing
about
the guy and writing about his findings
and kind of collecting it into a to a
little treat i see i see
gary and i spoke briefly over email
afterward and gary said the following to
me with the caveat of letting the
audience know that this is not what gary
actually thinks is quote unquote true
it's simply interesting mathematics that
expands one's thinking on the matter
look at the last sentence of this
document fascinating emergent property
he claims again i don't know if this is
true or anything it's just fun to think
about the quote is moreover they can
continue to exist autonomous as persona
without material reconnection basically
consciousness or a soul once created can
exist independently what is not explored
in figure 9 of the paper he sets up
humans as the last in the series of
entities that are created through his
physics starting at bioforce bracket
minimal sets of organization of
space-time objects close bracket up
through animals and primates with humans
as the last in the series
what might be next
i haven't done much research on this but
what are your thoughts on remote viewing
since we're on a similar tangent
well i think it's i mean like that guy
tyler henry that i just spoke about um
with that on that netflix show
uh sweet sweet guy he's like 27 or so
um
and uh
i mean it's a form of coordinate revo
remote viewing
right that thing that that jacques uh
basically came up with the notion that
the
the the coordinate is really just a
focusing device
it's not the means and it's not even the
the position of the object you could be
any series of numbers it's just
something that
you use to
link to the
to the whatever it is you're trying to
see
so this guy tyler henry uses objects
from the person
that he's supposedly
seeing uh okay
and uh you know it's not that it has any
role i think other than something that
focuses this guy's mind to allow either
his purely mainstream intuitive
processes to come into play
or something stranger
and i'm you know i i don't know where to
fall except to say that
whatever he seems to do is remarkable no
matter how he does it
the sun released a 1500 page document
or a set of documents
related to ufos
now i'm not sure if you had a chance to
go through it even with the cursory
glance but if you did what stood out to
you and what do you think that what made
someone like you even you say wow that's
interesting i didn't know that
um
well
some of the cases that kit was talking
about most of what was in there that the
sun
uh focused on i haven't read the 1500
pages i you know
um my students would probably kill me if
i spent my time reading 1500 pages of
somebody else's stuff
rather than the papers i should be
editing
um
so of theirs
uh
no i i think
there's
there was frankly nothing new that i
didn't already know about the about the
biology cases
uh
because i've been talking with kid about
it for the last 10 years so i guess
there's nothing really i can say about
it i'm sorry
is there something that people should be
focusing on that they aren't that you're
wondering man people you're missing this
this is extremely crucial
whether it's in the sun or whether it's
in all of these ufo reports that we've
heard about
well let's separate the
the
biology versus the materials aspect of
it
what's
what's missing is a
focus on
well i say this many times the the data
collection
um
you know
bringing to bear
real science efforts at doing it and and
pointing out how little funding is going
into it
it's being done on a
you know
literally out of people's pockets
so the focus needs to be
on talking
to
friends family
you know uh political representatives
etc to say would you please fund this
and help us
understand it because the questions
aren't going away
so you know fund either the biology
studies or fund
the
you know the uh material studies that
are being done or should be done i mean
i i've talked about the stuff that i've
spent money on
uh personally myself
um
and and and my time
on it uh
you know it's
to do it right
you need to bring in for the materials
you need to bring real metallurgists
instrumentation that costs in the
millions
yeah you know it's and you can rent this
stuff you don't have to buy it you can
rent
time on somebody else's machines
um
but then you still need people to
analyze the data
so
you know getting together here's what i
would love to see somebody set up
is
you know
set up a consortium of people who have
statistical analysis and metallurgic
analysis that if i create the data
they'll help me analyze it and they'll
do it in a in a protected
data
um you know
cda you know somebody drives you know
writes a you know confidentiality
disclosure agreement so that you you get
to
you work on the data first
and it you know the day after you
collect the data somebody doesn't go to
twitter and put out some preliminary
garbage or say something about the data
that is you know that i as the principal
investigator know is not true
right because there's nothing worse than
than uh a preliminary data put out that
somebody else
says well you said this last year now
you're saying this here
right so
you know i would like to see somebody
make an effort to create some sort of a
an analytics group
that people like me could turn to to say
here there's a data help me understand
this
because i don't have the time to do it
you know and
so that would be great whether it's
biology or materials
so i i i want people to stop talking
about and arguing about
cases that happened long ago
and start
doing something prospective
right helping people do the analysis
now you know
mick west for all of the
uh times that i you know kind of joke
with him about his uh his seagulls
um with seagulls you know the oh online
he basically saying that the
you know some of the observations were
seagulls and stuff like this i mean it's
just
ridiculous but i mean at least he has
reached out and done some of the
analysis even though i think his
analysis is faulty
this is what scientists do they argue
with somebody else's analysis
which is a good thing
right because you know at least at least
somebody's trying
um you know and others then came out and
said okay well the gimbal video you
analyzed it wrong mick sorry
you know it's you know uh
so
we need
we need sort of uh an organization that
somebody can turn to to vet the data for
us
you know and and
i mean i'm involved with with lou and
and others in trying to set something
like that up
you know because if no one else is going
to do it do it yourself so we'll set it
we'll set something like that up
and that's independent from the galileo
project
well no there's there's i mean the the
gala
one of the problems uh that way and i
you know i'm i'm now part of the galileo
project and they're doing some you know
amazing stuff
um is making sure that we aren't
uh
that they have a clear set of goals
and
um
but those goals are ever expanding
because of course they're looking uh
into some of the societal implications
and things underneath and behind it um
so whatever it is that we
create i don't want to overlap with
stuff that they're already doing
um
so you know that's why it's a good thing
for me to be part of both of these
operations
as we get them off the ground
what i was going to say before is that
to speak in defense of someone like mick
west is that i happen to like people
even if i'm not saying mick west is
biased but imagine that he is that he
just doesn't believe the conclusion that
these that it's non-terrestrial
i happen to like speaking to people who
are biased only because they're the ones
who are most motivated to find some
argument that you would not have found
and sometimes their arguments are great
yeah
no i i don't mind him i i totally
respect him i brought him up primarily
because
he at least is trying
um i you know i wish in his let's say in
his twitter
uh like profile
he basically says he's a debunker
um
and
i don't like the term debunking because
it basically you says you're coming in
with a framework
looking to to
disprove um
i people have said that i'm a debunker
i'm not i'm just
i just want to explain i i come in with
an open mind on either side
um you know because i have as everybody
knows seen things that i personally
can't explain or experience things that
i personally can't explain
and they don't have any conventional
explanation um i'm biased because if
anything i'm trying to prove to myself
that what i saw
or experienced
was not
the easy thing that i could reach to to
say it was a uap or
or some sort of non-human intelligence
communicating with me so i
i have a i have a bias but i would be
perfectly happy to be proven
a hundred percent wrong
uh that any of this stuff is
uap or what have you except
again i can't
i can't uh
dismiss the testimonies of hundreds of
individuals
uh at some point you have to give weight
to that
in my mind
what are some of the experiences you
mentioned that you haven't mentioned
elsewhere because i'm sure people who
have followed you oh
well no i mean i i it's it's known that
i saw a craft as a young boy went right
over my head
um
you know 30 40 feet
above me right at tree level
um i had no idea what it was
when it happened i i didn't say oh
there's a ufo
it was silent
silent yeah
um
and
you know it's it was only sometime in my
20s or 30s
that it sort of clicked
i said well that was what you saw
because it always has been with me
you know and the reason it was with it
is with me because i went around to the
other
people in the neighborhood who to whom i
was delivering papers at the time
and uh
i said did you know did you see this
and explained it to them and they just
sort of looked at me like okay kid
here's your paper money you know go away
um
so that's uh
you know
that's what drives me
which is why i would you know call
myself an experiencer because i'm
looking to explain what it is that i saw
you know it isn't to me proof of
anything
but it's it's to me something that
shook me to my core
at the time did it when you were a kid
even yeah
yeah i mean
it it was just like this
how do you explain it you just say what
was that
so you remember when we talked about
that there are some people who
experience seeing some phenomenon or
some element
and there are some people who didn't who
are right beside them now in that were
there some people or was it just an
individual who saw and then others
didn't where what i'm asking for was in
was there inter-subjective agreement
between at least more than one person
yes yeah oh yeah in some of the cases
absolutely
yeah i mean i mean the the the council
bluffs case is is the one in point where
there were like three individuals from
different vantage points around the town
of council bluffs that all saw the same
thing
a a a glowing blinking object that then
dropped something
bright to the ground and it was bright
because it was molten metal
um and then they all arrived at the same
time pretty much and the police showed
up
uh thinking it was a plane crash
and there was a blob there was a giant
blob of molten metal on the ground and
we got the pictures and everything
uh the original pictures kind of
unfortunately those those uh polaroids
feign go faint over time actually if
there's a if there's a person out there
who knows how to restore old polaroids
to enhance the original colors that was
there it would be nice to for them to
reach out to me
because we have the original polaroids
earlier you mentioned and many people
mentioned this that it's it may be that
there is some component of projections
when it comes to uaps
and then
it can't be all that because like you
said yeah there's some physical evidence
and then i was thinking i've heard this
from many other people that
depending on the culture at a specific
time the beings if there are beings they
make themselves comprehensible to that
culture so for example perhaps they
appear to sylvan beings like woodland
beings or angels to later generations
right and technology to us to a godless
nation however i don't think it can be
just projections because when it comes
to the technology side there were
reports of ancient flying roman shields
right and the government also seems to
be in possession of actual craft which
means they're physical so what accounts
for this
well
there's two kinds of projections we
think of projection in terms of our
you know let's say current understanding
a projection of something on a
on a 2d
movie screen
right um
now
you can have sort of a holographic
projection
which is something which appears to be
there and you know as and is in and of
itself emanating or reflecting light
there's a projection of something
potentially into your head that makes
you think you see something
but you know again if you're talking
about a technology that's
you know millions of years ahead of us
maybe it can project material objects
you know jacques uses the term often
the phenomenon can take a hold of a
volume of of space
and make
a reality real
right it can it can literally
change
space and
manifest
uh material objects
that's a form of a projection
at that point does it still retain the
word projection because
if something was created here then it
persists in multiple people
well i mean the question is is what is
created
uh actually functional
here in our reality or is it just a
piece of plastic that's moved from
behind the scenes and made to look like
it does something
so for instance let's talk about the
so-called craft that people see i mean
i would like to think that there's an
object with a physics
and
a
a physics that can be understood
from
sitting here in our 3d 4d world
but
maybe
let's say there's a multi-dimensional
reality and whatever it is that is
driving these objects sits somewhere
else and it's basically something that
it pokes into our reality
and it's it's moving it from
elsewhere
it's made to look like it's moving
here
but it has no functionality here the
functionality doesn't reside in our
side of of the of the veil the
functionality is elsewhere
so you know we might get one of these
objects
let's say let's say there's a crashed
craft or beings or whatever
and they are no more real
than
a you know a a sculpted object right
they they don't have the they don't have
the function here the function is driven
from elsewhere okay let me see if i get
this analogy so in there's this flat
land which i'm sure
and
so if you're a three just for the people
wondering what the heck that is as if
we're at least ostensibly 3d and then if
you look at your paper if you were to
touch your paper and there was an ant on
your paper that could only see what's on
the paper then all of a sudden they
would just see your fingernail and i
wonder what the heck is happening and
you can remove it and they would just be
gone and violate their laws of physics
so
the purpose would be like imagine if i
placed this cup down
on the piece of paper the cup is
actually for water for me to drink right
but these people see the bottom sliver
of a plastic and they're wondering well
what the heck is the purpose of this
well that's actually not the purpose of
it they would be
unreasonable for them to come up with
the purpose right well and and if you
were to now move it through their
flatland
left and right
they would see no
nor even if they were to look at the
object where it is
right the pieces of plastic that are
interfacing in their 2d they would see
no visible means of propulsion
the propulsion the propulsion is your
hand
moving it left right and center
so imagine that this is what's going on
here that there's something else that's
it's it's the the the motility the the
functionality is sitting elsewhere
uh and then what is here is just like i
said like a projection which is being
held at arm's length and the purp
because even looking at this which is a
light right if at the bottom there's
just a base that's black and they would
right they would have a hard time coming
up with the purpose of that based on the
base so you know i think we have to um
be prepared for some disappointments in
a way because if if what i just said is
is true
we might get a hold of some of these
things and never figure out how they
work because
the the engine is not here
but the driving force is not here and
and so
you know it's it's but it is still a
puppet which is used to interact with or
in jacques
sense of the term
is the control feature the control
function
uh the control system
is it still gets us to do stuff we still
dance around like a bunch of you know
like a bunch of monkeys when we see this
stuff
um and
its purpose whatever that might be is
is fulfilled
the monkey saw us
and then the monkeys will infer that
there is an intelligence behind it and
that's all we ever wanted them to do
to think bigger
to explore to explore the notion that
they're not alone
uh and maybe to
you know to
learn how to do this themselves someday
yeah
like they don't want to reveal too much
because that's giving away the answer in
particular it's giving away the answer
for us to come up with in our own on our
own yeah exactly yeah and these are some
of the things i've said before is that
you know you you you never
you you don't give your child everything
you teach them and let them make a few
mistakes are there people from the
government who
watch every one of your appearances
perhaps even watch the appearances of
people like lou to make sure that you're
not revealing too much
and if so who are these people are there
multiple individuals the department do
they tap your phone
no well
i just got to be careful what i say i
mean i have been told i should make the
assumption that the things
that i
say are being watched not just by us but
by others
um
and uh
so obviously i i try to be care i try to
hold all confidences
that i'm
either sworn to or agree to
you know
as best as possible
at one level i can't worry about these
people
right i mean i i i've got to just do
what it is that i'm doing
uh until somebody tells me not to do
something i'm gonna do it you know i'm
not you know or if it's obvious i
shouldn't be doing i'm not gonna do it
i'm not gonna put myself or my family in
danger
but i have
i've not felt that way
uh
you know i mean i'm not so much worried
about the government i'm worried about
this there's any of a number of people
who are um let's say unstable out there
in the in the world have nothing to do
with the government who will be
convinced that i'm
doing something that i should be stopped
you know i'm part of some grand
conspiracy or
i know somebody asked a question on that
thread about
am i being paid for
by something that i haven't disclosed as
if
i as if there's an agenda driving my
my every word
no
not yet at least
gary
thank you very much
no i mean thank you so much we've had
we've had this sort of personal you know
what are our uh
uh mental
issues or attempts to
be more um productive
uh you know and
you know i also want you to know and
people to know that like luckily luckily
man like i'm i mean
i'm generally an extremely
psychologically stable person some of
those experiences that i mentioned
recently have set me on edge so i'm so
hyper sensitive now that i wouldn't call
myself stable right now
but generally i am and i'm lucky for
that
and you seem like you're stable as well
so that's good despite your experiences
supposedly yeah
some of my colleagues might not agree
but that's okay
all right man take care and i will
ask you for that
book if you don't mind well you can just
give me the title and i'll get it i'll
send you the title yeah okay all right
take care my friend thanks so much kurt
okay bye bye goodbye
so now the podcast is over it's
generally frustrating maybe you're
experiencing the same where there's a
dearth of content new information when
it comes to the ufo scene and it feels
like plenty of ground is being trodden
and then re-trodden
and so for me one of the reasons that i
focus on the physics and the
consciousness is because there's plenty
that's new and even inspirational there
that is it inspires some other ideas for
possible connections to uaps and if
you're watching the toe podcast
primarily for the ufo content i
recommend that you at least check out
one of the physics videos or one of the
consciousness videos there's plenty
that's rich there that's new that is
inextricably tight or me let's not say
inextricably tight but has implications
for the phenomenon however at the same
time i'm not
dismayed whenever someone goes over the
same ground
repeatedly because there's plenty that
can be gained by viewing some phenomenon
from different slightly different
perspectives so for example even when
someone publishes a peer-reviewed paper
with data it's often still insightful to
interview the scientist and find out
well what worked and what didn't work
and what data was excluded and what data
is extraneous and why do you think that
it's extraneous and that gives you
insight into the initial data despite
the data being the same i believe i
spoke about this on the podcast with
jordan peterson where he invited me onto
his platform i was blessed enough for
that to have occurred and so i'll leave
a link in the description if you'd like
to hear more one should also know i'm
undecided as to how much i'm going to be
continuing to explore ufos alone rather
than ufos as connected to physics and
consciousness however one of the reasons
why one should explore despite the
ground being the same that they're
covering is that
at least in mathematics and physics it's
known
that one can almost never
investigate something rudimentary too
much that there's often extreme insight
to be gained that when you think you
understand something as simple as let's
say a compact space then terry tao comes
out with an article and you realize okay
my understanding has deepened despite me
thinking was at the maximum that it
could be same with kalama gorov who's
famous for kalmogorov complexity so
you'd think he'd come out with articles
about
what is complicated he had a whole essay
a whole essay just on the equal sign and
you thought well i understand what the
equal sign is until you read kamagorov's
essay so plenty can be gleaned just from
re-trotting the same ground i understand
that at the same time okay thank you so
much for watching and as i said in the
beginning there's an april fool's video
called ranking of toes or the ranking of
the toes i recommend you watch that if
you want to get a different flavor on
this channel i put plenty of time and
effort into that and people seem to
enjoy it
so hopefully you will as well plenty of
jokes made about some of the figureheads
in the ufo scene take care
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you
you